oh all right
why does Sam have an airsoft gun out
right now well the reason is we received
an electric bicycle in the mail the
other day and what we're going to do
right now is we're going to play a
Russian Roulette between everyone in the
studio even the last man standing wins
the electric bike wouldn't hit me
wouldn't it oh hey come on come on we
won say we fight back what city bike
we bought any bike or not if you don't
mind I have a feeling this was going to
hit anymore been afraid inverted come on
don't think about it people I just don't
forgive others why do you guys make me
do oh you're not making you we're all
doing have you don't do it great dress
welcome heard you're not want to play
this game yeah seriously
are you points no a serious question
keeps playing the game come on red
I really have not got any worse the good
news is that there's one person
eliminated we all have a higher chance
of getting like bad news we're all
eventually going to get shot you lose
fievel's hub G props that Jake is
working on up and back room for me he
does hacking off from thanks
[Music]
or ears it who are you
my god you're me
no no you're me No ah interesting news
so we have some visitors today
er landlord along with two fire safety
insurance guys other big David is
reevaluating the fire insurance policy
in the building and making sure that all
the code and requirements of the date so
that they are one willing to keep
insuring us into not raising our rates
to cover the lack of code reports right
so now they love the fact I'll say they
love all the clearly properly ticketed
and tagged
fire extinguishers they said Oh Haley
guys who drive every 20 more and you got
a fire extinguisher every 50 feet you
look incredible and then they started
looking for all these other things
hey nice Adam Saturday no yeah man that
that is a pitch I got another one of the
kids did yeah man are you kidding me
that is like manna to some I would be
where to serve Safari
wow that is a great that is a beautiful
hat that is the beautiful house okay
well she the guy we just created about
twelve
twelve new dollars with the work oh yeah
I got a lot all the all the smoke alarms
that are in this building I get to
switch them out with carbon monoxide hey
you guys thank you Susie hi today there
is a brand new shirt in the corridor
store it is what you see before you this
is actually one of my favorite design
we've done this year because it is super
weird but this one is the corridor
digital systems shirt designed by gender
Tom's once again ten days only
so this suits your fancy or would match
your other attire pick one up right now
before we stop Oh
show myself in the same exact spot I hit
my head wall here this morning hide your
helmet all this morning geez good reason
why here we go here we go here we go
here we go got no ebike damn good when
I'm driving arteries yeah after a hard
reset our bad luck is real bullets this
is the BB that killed Jay can read we're
down to three
we got Christian freelance nature guess
Sam there's gonna go know you're going
to kno know who am i handing this super
hand mission itself no I'm gonna do it
and then who am i handing up in any
Christian Christian oh you can't do with
the head you just kind of bear - yeah no
no I leave it on my head alright alright
it's between two people and this meeting
has killed Nick ran and myself is that
does that this is that I can do my
backups one sec
hey yo Pierre I get you to dial back the
sharpness on this shot thank you Peter
Peter fortitude decided to kill on my
friends and now we're here messing the
story oh my god are you gonna do well we
got out of here there's only one way you
need helping us just quick to walk out
front doors and we'll act to escape
that's all I have to do all you got to
do man just do it now quickly as
possible okay I'll do right now just
dark
okay don't ya
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right I'm gonna get out here
whoo siga head up rabbi can I get your
point but you don't have to be right
ahead
that's a real price or you'll get your
fight okay well the real prize is that I
don't have to experience getting shot or
shooting myself in the head with an
airsoft gun go get your bike honey I'll
get it eventually
fire inspector came by I think we have
some pretty good news some good news and
then some not-so-great banana here you
mean bad yeah I guess bad news what's
the medium the medium news is that we
have to get a handrail to the left side
of the staircase we have to get
earthquake proof straps for the water
heater and all plugs within a certain
radius of any water supply have to get
like a different outlet that's the
medium use and the reason it's medium
news is because speed is taken care of
all the stuff we covering that's like
that that is is that they took a look at
our workshop and basically anything
flammable in this office including spray
paint
mineral spirits where does it need to be
anything is we need a base to be
purchased a containment locker which is
a big doubles a triple pane metal Locker
that contain any explosive type of thing
oh hey at least they didn't see the
fireworks
oh one more thing about that how much I
think how much is this container talk
about the small what yes basically we
need to contain anything flammable
especially the aerosol stuff like all
the favourite cans on the floor and
stuff we have to get a locker similar to
this that contains it has a locking
doors so then if there is explosion if
it's mostly contained within that area
or is in the locker that's on up and
that is on us to pay for because it is
not very faint about sometimes the
building has baked chocolate something
that we have here as a luxury to our XD
so that is something that we have to
purchase enough he also suggest whatever
we do purchase we pass on that
recommendation to Spencer and Brandon
because they are also in violation
conceal violate I'm not going to say
what this is I'm just going to go into
it ready yeah
[Music]
well we've got these a Tron one's name
is Richard lenders and the other
district enjoyer akin alien booty
[Music]
we've got Timothy Thompson longtime fan
and Sean Witt - he's right there
and so hog lie aka Psilakis hero finally
there's James Bailey and Brian and
Togiak I hope I pronounced that right
because you are here again this month it
means I must have thanks guys thanks for
your support
yeah if you're interested in helping us
make videos consider checking out
patreon.com/crashcourse or digital link
below
[Music]
one more for the road
[Music]